it was difficult to leave home to leave
your family your brother and people
important around you and people
especially your love
for years the number of migrants
crossing the channel in small boats has
steadily increased no no no no no we are
waiting for something no no we don't
need help thank you
in 2021 there were record numbers of
migrants crossing on a single day
but why do they come
how do they come and how should the uk
handle immigration
for those fleeing persecution and
crippling poverty the uk is an
attractive place to live
citizens of some countries face
persecution for their religion ethnicity
beliefs and sexual orientation
and now the world's worsening climate
conditions are making some areas
uninhabitable
as a result increasing numbers of people
have sought to migrate to the uk in
search of a better life
there are different types of migration
as the uk continues to grow its economy
there are numerous jobs where migrants
are needed and for this work visas can
be used
from the time you decide you need new
specialist doctors it takes a minimum of
10 sometimes 15 years to
really
train them these doctors come already
trained in terms of monetary value
that's very cheap
companies in the uk can legally sponsor
individuals provided they demonstrate
that they are unable to find british
citizens who can do the same work
however it can be expensive and
time-consuming
[Music]
visas are also granted for students who
come to the uk
then there are asylum seekers those
fleeing persecution war or adverse
conditions caused by climate change
under the u.n refugee convention
countries have an obligation to allow
asylum seekers to stay in the uk for the
duration of an asylum claim
and they have a duty to process that
claim if these claims are successful
asylum seekers can go on to live in the
uk with a pathway to future citizenship
10 years later
the uk actually registers fewer
first-time asylum applicants than many
other eu countries in 2020 for instance
the highest number of first-time asylum
applicants was registered in germany
followed then by spain france and greece
contrast all of that with the uk
should we got a warrant could you open
the door please
anyone who is not in the process of
seeking asylum or does not have a work
or student visa
okay we'll be entering the uk illegally
it is difficult to know how many people
have successfully entered the uk and are
living illegally due to them not having
any records although one estimate puts
the numbers between 800 000 and 1.2
million
with the knowledge that some countries
are less hostile to migrants than others
both in attitudes and benefits many
prefer to continue onwards to their
preferred destinations
this has created tension between the uk
and france who the uk government
believes should be responsible for
processing asylum seekers attempting to
cross the channel
this problem has become more acute in
recent years as the number of people
crossing the channel in small boats has
increased rapidly
in 2018 just 286 people made the journey
but by 2020 nearly
8500 attempted it and in 2021 over 10
000 had tried in the first six months
every year it's increased
dramatically i mean three years ago when
we first started to sort of come across
these
small boats coming across the channel
there would just be the odd one here and
there whereas now every flat calm day
you can guarantee that there's going to
be a large number of migrant dingies
coming across they're regular as
clockwork now
in an attempt to take control of the
situation home secretary pretty patel
signed a 54 million pound deal with
france so they could increase policing
on their side of the border
hello
but this has been criticized within the
uk for not being good value for money
we've given them 31.5 million euros last
year and you're now about to give them
another 54 million pounds to do the same
thing
why will it be different this time the
french are not doing their part
all of this also detracts from the fact
that people who cross in the boats
usually want to be rescued and go on to
claim asylum and don't actually make up
the majority of illegal immigration
the least common route is clandestine
entry so for instance um coming across
the english channel in a small boat we
hear a lot about that but that's that's
pretty uncommon it's more likely that
people become
undocumented or having a regular
migration status because they came to
the uk legally
perhaps on a visa
and then overstayed the length
of that visa
[Music]
most migrants enter europe from three
points greece italy and spain
in 2019 there are about 60 000 arrivals
to greece 11 500 to italy and 26 000
arrivals to spain
the majority stay in those three
countries but some move on throughout
europe eventually reaching france those
who come to the uk from the english
channel tend to have made journeys from
halfway across the world
iranians make up 51 of migrants crossing
the channel and iraq second most with 26
according to the home office the next
most represented nations are syria
afghanistan yemen and sudan
asylum seekers are typically placed into
government care for the duration of
their claims these can be hotels
temporary accommodation or bespoke
asylum centers
it can take a while with one 2021
refugee council reports claiming that
the average wait time is between one and
three years
and there have been frequent criticisms
of the standard of care for those who
arrive with reports of people being
given inadequate food and being denied
essentials such as shoes all that before
their legal status which can leave them
without ability to earn money for years
people who don't have access to council
housing or homelessness assistance and
in some cases aren't legally allowed so
they got paid employment people in that
situation will become what is called
destitute it means that local
authorities like children's services
will often have to provide support but
it's a direct consequence of restrictive
policies aims to
prevent
undocumented migration but actually
catches people in destitution and
actually increases costs to government
it just changes it from local from
central government to local government
migration continues to be a live
political issue for the uk as it does
across europe even post-brexit for which
it was a major issue but views have
softened slightly since the voters both
leavers and remainers both view the
impact of immigration on the uk economy
a little less negatively on average than
they did before
but as global britain seeks to assert
itself on the world stage it's likely
the debate around immigration won't be
going away anytime soon